today I'm going to go over the top three
careers that are currently in high
demand do not require a college degree
can often be done remotely have good
starting pay and have the potential to
be good long-term careers the first
career on my list is technology sales
also known as business development or
sales development instead of selling
small items and services to Average
Joe's technology sales focuses on
selling software and Tech to businesses
and this career path has a much higher
ceiling in terms of growth it's a path
that many CEOs of companies have taken
before in the past the second type of
career on our list is it is a term that
covers a wide variety of support
positions in the digital world if you
take a look at this image here you'll
see the many potential Paths of this
career the majority of these later
positions are high paying with salaries
ranging from 100 to 300 000 the third
career path on our list is called
digital marketing digital marketing
simply put is helping companies with
their online marketing efforts the
average starting salary can range
anywhere from forty to fifty thousand
dollars entry level